bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi et 17
février merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 le journal
tout de suite on commence avec les
titres de cette édition
quel site pourrait accueillir les jeux
olympiques de 2024 le dossier parisien
vient d'être dévoilée le département des
yvelines est concerné présentation et
réactions à suivre les des logements
spécialement conçu pour les étudiants à
montigny le bretonneux le chantier est
en cours
155 logements devraient être livrés
d'ici l'été 2016 et enfin c'est l'année
de tous les anniversaires pour la
bergerie nationale de rambouillet elle
fête ses 30 ans d'ouverture au public et
les deux cent trente ans de ses moutons
mérinos une année marquée par des temps
forts pour nous en parler en plateau
frédéric andrieu responsable de la ferme
pédagogique sera notre invité et je vous
le disais dans les titres les
responsables du dossier des jeux
olympiques de 2024 ont présenté
aujourd'hui à la philharmonie de paris
les contours du projet parisien parmi
les sites retenus quatre sont dans les
yvelines les épreuves de cyclisme sur
route passeront par la vallée de
chevreuse et saint quentin en yvelines
les épreuves le château de versailles et
va accueillir les épreuves équestres et
le pentathlon le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines basée à
montigny le bretonneux organisera les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et de bmx
quant au golf national de guyancourt il
recevra les compétitions de golf bien
évidemment une épreuve qui reviendra
dans le programme olympique de cet été à
rio au brésil
enfin saint quentin en yvelines
organisera également les compétitions de
vtt sur la colline des longs cours un
site qui culmine à plus de 230 m on
écoutait la réaction du cycliste et
nîmes on tient françois pervis il était
évidemment ravi de cette annonce
ce serait vraiment incroyable pour le
sport français en général surtout pour
pour nous et pour moi unis montrent un
avoir les jeux olympiques en france ça
voudrait dire que visiblement toutes les
épreuves du cyclisme serait dans la
région de montigny ses alentours
donc ce serait vraiment incroyable ya le
vélodrome couvert ça permettrait de
continuer dans le projet de
développement du cyclisme à voir tout ça
à proximité ce serait se serait serait
énorme
les amateurs de cyclisme sur piste vont
une nouvelle fois vibrer au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
après les championnats du monde
organisés en février 2015
l'enceinte sportive organisera les
championnats d'europe cette année du 19
au 23 octobre
le public pourra voir des têtes
d'affiché comme les limons un françois
pervis six fois champion du monde favori
pour obtenir une médaille aux jeux
olympiques de rio
le président de la fédération française
de cyclisme david lappartient était au
micro de michael me d'euros on les
écoute il ya une certaine logique
il ya d'abord une logique d'accueillir
de grands événements on a la chance
d'avoir un vélodrome exceptionnel quand
on a vu l'élan qu'on a eue au
championnat du monde
on a eu envie finalement de continuer à
avoir des grands événements on avait
cette opportunité puisque 2017 étaient
déjà attribués à berlin 2018 à glasgow
et on a saisi l'opportunité et urbanisme
à présent après la dernière résidence
étudiants qui vrai près du vélodrome en
juin dernier c'est au tour d'une
résidence pour doctorants de sortir de
terre d'ici l'été prochain
quatre mille cinq cents mètres carrés de
logement étudiant sur cinq étages à
proximité de la gare de saint-quentin
divine et du vélodrome
les détails avec ses fours al dahmani et
patrick jacques de dixmude 155 logements
étudiants verront bientôt le jour avec
la nouvelle résidence pour doctorants de
l'architecte grossi un projet mené par
saint quentin en yvelines pour répondre
à la demande croissante de logements des
enseignants chercheurs dans le supérieur
chercheur en laboratoire ou encore
doctorat en entreprise
la dimension chercheurs enseignants
supérieur à 150 a appris beaucoup
d'efforts ces dernières années et donc
il est intéressant sur un territoire
novation de recherche et d'enseignement
supérieur de permettre à des doctorants
ou des chercheurs de pouvoir se loger
sur des durées moyennes ou courtes sur
le territoire à proximité des centres de
recherche et des laboratoires 4500 m²
structurée sur cinq étages en studios et
deux pièces des logements de 22 à 40
mètres carrés avec toilettes et salle de
bain privative un bâtiment conçu pour
répondre pleinement à l'offre étudiante
avec 1000 m² au rez-de-chaussée dévolu à
différents commerces et lieux de
restauration les lieux d'habitat les les
chambres la capacité de pouvoir cuisine
qui peut dans les chambres d'avoir des
espaces communs adapté à ce type de
public pour pouvoir travailler
ponctuellement il ya quelques salles de
travail et puis quelques lieux de
rencontres dans l'immeuble au niveau des
étages cette nouvelle structure proche
de la gare fait partie des sept nouveaux
projets immobiliers à proximité du
vélodrome et sera livré d'ici l'été
prochain les collèges et lycées du
département étaient invités cet après
midi à prendre part à la mobilisation
lancé par le syndicat snes 78 le rendez
vous avait lieu à 15h devant la
direction académique de guyancourt si
l'établissement ont répondu à l'appel
des professeurs du collège de la cantine
et à noisy le roi mais aussi des
collèges de verneuil-sur-seine et
sartrouville ont fait le déplacement
il dénonce les conséquences de la
réforme du collège sur la rentrée 2016
d'autres actions devraient être menées
dans le courant du mois de mars delphine
romani secrétaire du snes 78 craint que
cette réforme ne supprime des options ou
des enseignements en 2000 groupe
on l'écoutait les têtes au micro de
camille lambert on a une réponse du
collège qui a été annoncé par la
ministre comme quelque chose d'ambitieux
qui est de l être à la hauteur des
attentes du système éducatif est en fait
ce qu'on constate c'est que les moyens
ne sont pas ce qu'on souhaite c'est que
les établissements soient reçus que leur
demande soit entendu qui puisse
expliquer de combien d'heures ils ont
besoin pour ouvrir leurs options pour
permettre des dédoublements pour alléger
les classes et puis on espère qu'ils
obtiendront les moyens dont ils ont
besoin effectivement et la délégation a
bien été reçue par la direction
académique de la dsd n 78 lors de ce
reportage
les discussions étaient encore en cours
et nous passons maintenant à notre
entretien 2016 c'est l'année de tous les
anniversaires pour la bergerie nationale
de rambouillet elle fête les 30 ans de
l'ouverture de son site au public
pour nous en parler en plateau ce soir
fait frédéric et driout bonsoir vous
êtes responsable de la ferme pédagogique
alors vous faites également un autre
anniversaire celui des moutons mérinos
de la race des moutons mérinos est un
des fleurons de la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet le mérinos de rambouillet
tendon unique au monde
il a fait la renommée de l'établissement
au fil des siècles et cette année il
fête ses 200 30 ans depuis son arrivée
en france en 1786 la race a été
conservée intacte
on en parle avec vous dans quelques
instants juste après ce reportage
consacré au fameux moutons et réalisé
par camille lambert regarder
à peine âgée de quelques jours et déjà
debout cet agneau ne le sait pas mais il
fait partie d'une grande lignée de
moutons il est le descendant des mérinos
espagnols arrivés à rambouillet en 1786
une race devenue unique au monde
le mérinos étant reconnue pour la
qualité de sa laine à l'époque déjà on
l'a ramené pour pouvoir améliorer la
qualité de l'air en france et donc notre
rôle aujourd'hui pour ce mouton c'est de
le garder tel qu'il est arrivé il ya 230
ans aujourd'hui cette année à cette
période c'est la naissance des petits
les moutons sont donc tendus pour
faciliter l'allaitement
contrairement aux autres races le
mérinos et couverts de laine sur tout le
corps du museau au bout des pattes la
bergerie nationale veille à sa
conservation et organise des activités
pour le faire découvrir au public
l'heure du repas est un moment attendu
visiteurs comme des locataires
c'est un petit peu la nouvelle référence
de l'établissement donc lors des visites
guidées c'est l'animal par lequel on
passe forcément pour expliquer un petit
peu d origine de la ferme et l'intérêt
de garder sa trace aujourd'hui en france
la majorité des races de moutons sont
issus de croisements le mérinos de
rambouillet fait donc office d'exception
et attire même les touristes étrangers
plusieurs journées lui seront consacrées
cette année rendez vous sur le site
internet de la bergerie nationale ça
déride réjoui regardez reportage avec
attention avant nous tout dit sur le
mérinos alors c'était pas mal c'est pas
mal c'est bien vous êtes donc les seuls
à posséder cette race quand cela
s'explique vous nous faire un petit
cours d'histoire on veut pouvoir les
gérer de a à z donc effectivement c'est
une race arrivé il ya 230 ans donc c'est
l'élevage avec le taux de consanguinité
le plus élevé au monde donc on ne peut
pas faire n'importe quoi c'est un
troupeau qui suivit au niveau national
et effectivement c'est à la bergerie que
les croisements se font donc on veut que
les choses se fassent correctement donc
ça ne peut être fait qu'à la bergerie
donc c'est ce qu'il est il n'y aucun
autre élevage de moutons mérinos
ailleurs en france il ya d'autres traces
de mérinos mais le mérinos de
rambouillet comme son nom l'indiqué ne
peut le trouver car oui alors il
participe à votre popularité montante à
l'europe protège ils font venir des
touristes de l'étranger oui oui on a
beaucoup de effectivement c'est comment
s'étaient dits dans le dos dans le
reportage c'est le fleuron de
l'établissement et les gens viennent
avant tout à l'origine pour ça même si
maintenant la bergerette et est connu
pour pour plein d'autres choses
alors justement a donc l'année 2016
devrait être ponctuée de plusieurs
événements tous les mois il y en aura
aussi organisé justement autour du
fameux moutons voilà donc comme les
moutons sont arrivés en 1786 au mois
d'octobre donc fin septembre début
octobre on a un événementiel autour de
l'arrivée
l'arrivée des moutons donc on va faire
une mini transhumance dans la ville de
rambouillet et un gros événement sur la
bergerie donc c'est vraiment une année
très importante pour nous et tous les
mois il va y avoir donc des événements
vous nous en dire un peu plus voilà on
le mois de février était consacrée début
février était consacrée justement la
tonte des moutons comme sept présentés
dans le reportage généralement les
moutons sont tendus au début du
printemps bon on est encore en hiver
mais bon c'est généralement février
février mars
donc c'était la tonte des moutons aparté
par contre le mois prochain donc au mois
de mars
fin mars
week-end de pâques on a un gros
événement autour de la basse cour
pendant les vacances et pendant les
vacances voilà donc là c'est les
animations plutôt thématiques à
destination de toute la famille à la
fois enfants adultes professionnels et
pendant les vacances voilà il ya un
thème qui est déclinée donc le thème des
vacances de février c'est une animation
autour de la thématique du cirque et du
carnaval alors depuis 30 ans vous êtes
ouvert au public c'est difficile de
maintenir un tel site ouvert voilà
depuis tant d'années ont fait de mieux
en mieux ça fait deux ans qu'on a passé
le cap des cent mille visiteurs donc
voila c'était un peu un objectif
effectivement on a la fierté de dire
qu'on est le quatrième site le plus
visité des yvelines et donc cent mille
visiteurs pour nous c'est bien parce
qu'il ya un vrai relationnel avec nos
clients donc un tout dans tout dans le
cadre manquant même important voilà mais
c'est vrai que c'est un travail de
longue haleine est un travail de tous
les jours pour fidéliser les clients
pour réussir à toujours être dans la
qualité
c'est le volet pédagogique citi prime a
peut-être autant de visiteurs
effectivement on est là on est la plus
grande ferme pédagogique de france donc
on est dans la capacité de répondre à
des programmes scolaires donc
effectivement les enseignants viennent à
la bergerie pour travailler sur des
programmes scolaires
que ce soit les cycles 1 2 3 ou même des
collèges et on est en train de
développer des animations sur
l'agroécologie plus à destination de
professionnels ou de houe de l'isère
justement vous placer l'année 2016 sous
le signe de l'agriculture biologique
alors ça c'est fini tu croyais avoir des
grands changements à la bergerie
nationale pour passer en pour devenir
une ferme
en agriculture biologique ça ne se fait
pas en un jour donc c'est un travail de
aussi de très longue haleine
donc il a fallu déjà passé les terres
parce que la priorité c'est de nourrir
les animaux donc on nourrit les animaux
avec ce qu'on produit dans nos champs et
dans nos prairies
donc il a fallu déjà passé notaire en
agriculture biologique donc ça s'est
fait en 2015
et là il faut à peu près six mois et
donc en mai 2000 2016 nos vaches seront
officiellement d'agriculture biologique
après il ya un autre objectif sera de
faire passer les moutons mais ça c'est
un travail qui est un petit peu plus
compliqué mais voilà déjà au mois de mai
2016 donc comme je vous le disais en
mars et la basse cour en mai ce sera au
tour des vaches laitières et donc de son
passage au bio alors c'est aussi l'année
l'occasion de fêter les 70 ans de la
mise au point des techniques
d'insémination à la bergerie nationale
faisait office de modèle qu'en est il
maintenant il ya des choses qui vont
changer également de ce côté là
l'exploitation et la bergerie d'une
façon générale depuis louis saez a
toujours été un établissement précurseur
dans les innovations agricoles
donc effectivement il ya 70 ans on a
demandé à la bergerie ça a été la houle
a été testé les première insémination
artificielle donc l'équipe est toujours
existante et on est en train de
justement de montrer qu'on peut aussi en
agriculture biologique en agriculture
raisonnée faire de l'insémination
artificielle
alors les procédés un petit peu
justement vous vont évoluer vous allez
passer des semis également au salon de
l'agriculture c'est aussi l'occasion de
se montrer et de faire vivre la bergerie
exactement
voilà on a quand même des personnes
référentes au niveau national qui sont
acquis sont à la bergerie qu'ils vont
être présents au salon de l'agriculture
je pense à deux collègues qui
historiquement ils sont tous les ans
pour représenter la bergerie avec nos
animaux les moutons mais aussi pour
participer à des jurys autour du métier
de berger autour de l'agriculture de
l'agro écologie donc on a tous les ans
des personnes qui sont présentes et vous
former également des jeunes au métier
voilà de la ferme ça ça change ça évolue
on voit c'est une priorité aussi pour la
bergerie on accueille fréquemment des
stagiaires des formations plus ou moins
longues sur différents types de métiers
qui sont toujours des métiers liés à la
grille coll
beaucoup d'animateurs aussi un mois en
tant que responsable de l'équipe
d'animation j'accueille des animateurs
en formation qui potentiellement un jour
de travaillant dans des structures comme
la nôtre merci beaucoup frédéric durieux
d'avoir répondu aux questions voile
alors si vous voulez plus d'informations
n'hésitez pas à aller sur le site
internet de la bergerie nationale qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran voilà
est également plein d'événements qui
vont contre 8 cette année chez merci
beaucoup monsieur nous passons
maintenant à la santé le rire contribuer
au bien-être c'est du moins ce que
pensent plusieurs thérapeute qui
l'utilisent pour atténuer la douleur
mais aussi tisser un lien social aux
clayes-sous-bois l'association qu'ahmad
vient en aide aux personnes âgées et
handicapées de différentes manières et
notamment par le rire marie thérèse rose
présidente de l'association de
n'utiliser une conférence pour expliquer
et démontrer les bienfaits de ce procédé
un reportage plein de bonne humeur et
réalisé par william l
rires mais surtout avec tout le monde
voilà le message que délivre
l'association qu'ahmad clayes-sous-bois
rire pour aller mieux ou pour atténuer
la douleur parité réseau rose présidente
de l'association donne les clés de la
thérapie par le rire le rire produit des
tas de substance et de
neurotransmetteurs et 2 fort is an qui
permettent effectivement de lutter
contre le stress mais pas que ça ça peut
permettre aussi d'avoir une main une
meilleure digestion
parce que comme vous riez par exemple
c'est un exemple au kotel bouge donc
elle fait une sorte de massage sur
l'estomac l'intestin et le foie donc ça
fait des organes qui vaut mieux
fonctionné lors ira il est indispensable
à la vie
pour marie thérèse le rire joue sur la
qualité de vie et le bien-être
psychologique mais il est aussi vecteur
d'un lien social
maryse rohff et donne des cours de yoga
du rire rire communicatif et même
contagion et vous allez faire comme si
vous rugissiez comme un lion en sortant
lagord la langue
un exemple regardez le yoga du rire
c'est d'abord la prise de conscience de
son corps et de sa verticalité sans
jugement simplement un ressenti de son
corps de toutes les parties de son corps
celui qui est vraiment et que nous
faisons régulièrement parce que je tiens
à le faire c'est vraiment le rire du
d'union parce qu'il exprime vraiment
tout c'est vraiment la rolls royce du
rire aujourd'hui les français 10 de
moins en moins en moyenne une minute par
jour en 2015 contre une vingtaine en
1940 il ne tient plus qu'à vous
d'inverser cette tendance en le
propagent en est aujourd'hui dans la
chronique environnement va s'intéresser
au travail minutieux réalisé par les
équipes du parc national turrel régional
de la haute vallée de chevreuse alors
pendant six mois
elles ont recensé r'esp'air répertorier
des lieux les espèces sur le territoire
le fruit de leurs trois vraies leur
travail pardon c'est un observatoire du
climat pour nous emparer en plateau mais
l hypothèse en soirée à nice et sochaux
rennes alors l'idée de cet observatoire
est issu du conseil scientifique du parc
c'est gérard arnal dont je vous ai
présenté un ouvrage il ya quelques
semaines qui en est à l'initiative
le conseil a constaté que sur le pnr de
noms dont on trouve de nombreuses
espèces qui sont d'affinités montagnarde
et ses plantes se sont se maintiennent
en petit nombre mais suffisamment
important pour être des indicateurs
climatiques
olivier marchal est chargé d'études
environnement au parc naturel il nous
explique le principe
le principe est assez simple c'est de se
dire ces plans façon limites d'heures de
répartition on a du mal à les trouver à
ces altitudes de plaine se maintiennent
par petites populations petites tâches
et si on a globalement un réchauffement
climatique qui va s'accélérer
on devrait avoir
un impact sur ces plantes laon premier
donc l'idée c'est en suivant ces plantes
c'est un peu spécial
de corroborer ou de constater en
fonction le terrain le réchauffement
climatique alors le parc a recensé près
de 300 sites à travers ses archives et a
dû opérer une sélection parmi 48 espèce
de plante montagnarde supposé se
trouvait justement dans le parc
et c'est en fait une personne qui
s'occupait de cet inventaire c'est
alexandra potiers à l'époque elle était
stagiaire au parc elle est aujourd'hui
titulaire d'un master en gestion et
conservation de la biodiversité pendant
six mois elle s'est donc rendue sur les
différents sites et a fait le bilan des
inventaires qui existait déjà à l'époque
elle est identifié les lieux et les
espèces existant encore ce nouvel
inventaire a permis de découvrir que des
espèces avait créé et que certains qu'on
pensait disparue était toujours là des
difficultés particulières
ça a été un long travail de compiler
toutes les données qui existait déjà
donc c'était des des fois des très
anciennes données pas du tout précise
donc on avait une donnée qui datait de
1700 et quelques at elle enfin sur telle
commune c'était pas possible de
retourner sur le terrain la retrouver
par exemple on a retrouvé
comar et donc c'est une espèce de
milieux humides de tourbières c'était
une donnée au lieu-dit et qui n'avait
pas été revu depuis 1900 alors à l'issue
de ce travail très important il peut le
dire mais annie 52 stations ont été
choisis ainsi que seize espèces en
particulier et vous vous êtes justement
rendu sur l'un de ces sites mais on a
choisi avec les équipes d'aller à son
lit son valoir sur la carte
c'est tout proche du château de la
course en lice on est en amont de la
vallée de l'yvette alors sur ce lieu
c'est le politique à aiguillon une sorte
de fougères qui intéresse les équipes du
parc
et cette fois c'est olivier marchal qui
nous explique pourquoi ce choix ce
vallon illustrait bien en fait les
caractéristiques du parc naturel
régional à savoir par rapport au reste
de l'ile-de-france des petites vallées
un peu encaisser les froides dans
lesquels on va retrouver des plantes
plutôt d'affinités montagne à cela qu'on
trouve plutôt en france dans les massifs
montagneux et qui vont se retrouver par
endroits ont plein à l'occasion de deux
petits microclimat en fait de petits
endroits un peu abritait alors que nous
indique que ces premiers résultats
mélanie si certains sont déjà ressortir
y en a déjà
parce que la présence de ces fougères
dans cette zone a déjà donné des
informations
le climat dans ces vallons et donc
suffisamment froid et humide pour que
les fougères se sont maintenues et pour
avoir de vraies les deux meilleurs
résultats
l'état de lieux sera refait dans cinq
ans ça permettra de constater s'il ya
des nouveaux changements ou si la nature
que n'a pas bougé affaire à suivre
merci beaucoup à mélanie elle à présent
tout autre sujet depuis le mois de
janvier le célèbre dessinateur du
marsupilami rend visite aux élèves de
l'agglomération de versailles grand parc
alors une visite pas uniquement pour le
plaisir d'échanger
car dans le cadre d'un vaste projet
interdisciplinaire luc coene un colin
pardon connu sous le nom d'artiste de
baptême vient préparer l'agenda qui sera
ensuite distribué aux élèves des écoles
alentours
wilfrid vichy et camille lambert se sont
rendus à l'école élémentaire prés
saint-jean à buc
le marsupilami cet animal imaginaire né
en 1952 sous les coups de crayon du
dessinateur andré franquin reste
toujours autant populaires les plus
jeunes générations continuent à aduler
cette petite bête jaune aux taches
noires d'à peine un mètre ces aventures
aujourd'hui racontés par le dessinateur
baptême s'arrache dans les cours de
récréation
là c'est le nid avec la famille
marsupilami le bouchon qui est en train
de couper un arbre et
le marsupilami feraient attaquer et
depuis le mois de janvier ils sont 150
élèves de six classes issues de la
communauté d'agglomération de versailles
grand parc à travailler avec baptême
attentifs aux conseils du maître venu
spécialement depuis la belgique alors
rencontrent deux fois par semaine ils
préparent le prochain agenda scolaire
qui sera distribué dans les écoles du
secteur
ce à quoi je m'attendais pas c'est que
j'allais devoir un peu débattre du fond
et de trouver des idées ensemble sinon
il initialement mon but était de cadres
et de les canaliser les idées des
enfants pour les aider à illustrer pour
que les images soient claires nettes à
pact a recommandé aujourd'hui il est
très efficace
le projet mené avec l'éducation
nationale n'est pas uniquement culturel
la réalisation de cet agenda permet
également d'aborder la question de la
protection de l'environnement cause du
réchauffement climatique énergies
renouvelables ou encore éco gestes des
questionnaires notamment viendront
enrichir l'agenda questionnaire préparé
avec les enseignants ces riches parce
que y'a plein de champs disciplinaires
qui ce qui se mélangent le dessin qui
doit porter un message à la fois le
français avec toute la production
d'écrits et puis le côté scientifique
donc c'est vraiment très riche et ils
sont bien impliqués
andré frank était lui-même très sensible
à l'écologie et manger toujours été je
toujours été projet nature je faisais du
scoutisme et le marsupilami qui vit en
pleine nature et qu'il va défendre son
environnement
effectivement deux puis je dire dès le
troisième album même peut-être le
deuxième est essentiellement le
troisième album qui marque ce noir avec
liam nous avons prêté d'écologie 8500
l'agenda seront éditées pour septembre
compte à un baptême
aussitôt ce travail terminé il reviendra
dans les yvelines les 8 et 9 octobre à
buc en tant que parrain du festival de
bande dessinée cette fois ci c'est la
fin de ce décès de cette édition avant
nous quitter je vous rappelle
l'information principale de ce journal
les responsables dossier des jeux
olympiques de 2024 ont présenté
aujourd'hui à la philharmonie de paris
les contours du projet parisien parmi
les sites retenus quatre sont dans les
éviers
alors les épreuves de cyclisme sur route
passeront par la vallée de chevreuse et
saint quentin en yvelines
le château de versailles va accueillir
les épreuves équestres mais aussi le
pentathlon le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines basée à
montigny le bretonneux organisera les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et de bmx
quant au golf national de guyancourt
lieu s'il a été retenue il recevra les
compétitions de golf une épreuve qui
reviendra dans le programme olympique de
cet été à rio enfin saint quentin en
yvelines organisera également les
compétitions de vtt sur la colline
d'élan pour un site qui je le rappelle à
culmine à 230 m plus d'informations à
suivre jeudi on reviendra sur le sujet
avec les michael elle me d'euros dans
son talk show si on parlait sport il
faudra plus de détails tout de suite la
suivre sephora namani avec son magazine
culturel kiosque ne manquez pas
justement les différents reportages je
vous remercie d'avoir suivi je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée et vous
dis à demain